eigentlich ist es nicht nur
verachtenswert wenn auch ziemlich
verrückt dass der mensch so oft
homosexualität diskriminiert verachtet
oder sogar verfolgt im tierreich ist das
gott sei dank nicht so hier ist
homosexualität wie viele arten der
normalfall und kein tier wird dafür
bedroht oder angegriffen
das ist wirklich eine menschliche
spezialität sie also die top zehn
tierarten bei den homosexualität
einfach dazugehört fixum zweifel wissen
dass gekommen
vom tessin ist das walross nahezu alle
männlichen walrösser sind bis zu ihrem
vierten lebensjahr schwul und haben
ausschließlich sex mit anderen
männlichen walrösser er war nach
pflanzen sich mit weibchen fort aber das
auch nur während der fortpflanzungszeit
danach wird wieder mit den männlichen
artgenossen gekuschelt und geschlafen
die neue scharfe 8 prozent von ihnen
wählten den studien lieber einen
männlichen partner auf der 8 sind die
man kraken die männchen machen es meist
nur eine nacht lang allerdings suchen
zahlreiche weitere eine partnerin zu
bleiben mit ihr ein leben lang zusammen
geblieben wie sonst her ist sex unter
männlichen bisons der alltag die
weibchen lassen sich ja nur einmal im
jahr besteigen und so besteigen junge
liebe und viel öfter
geschlechtsgenossen als weibchen 6 und
solo wo sie sind sexuell ziemlich aktiv
eben auch mit dem gleichen geschlechts
am meisten sechs untereinander haben
diese ängsten verwandelt menschen unter
den weibchen zwei drittel des
homosexuellen sechs haben die weibchen
auf der 5 sind die schwäne 1 5 der
schwan fahrer sind schwul
um nachwuchs großzuziehen tat sich dann
einer der beiden schwäne mit einem
weibchen unser jagte
nachdem es die eier gelegt hat die 4 bei
den benzin sind alle bisexuell
gleichgeschlechtlicher oralsex unser
delfinen und es ihnen gehört zum sex
alltag homosexualität und
heterosexualität halten sich bei den
sündern die waage wobei die männchen
zeitweise auch ausschließlich
homosexuell auf der drei der albatrosse
genauer der lusaner albatrosse auf der
insel oahu sind 30 prozent der pärchen
letztlich dem monogramm und kleinen
zusammen für die befruchtung ihrer eier
sorgen samenspender menschen aus anderen
partnerschaften befruchten wie groß
gezogen werden sie könnten dann von den
letzten paar und auf der zwei giraffen
90 prozent des access bei den langen
hälsen ist homosexuell
sie lieben es ihre hälse aneinander zu
reiben das ist dann das vorspiel das
dann allerdings nicht immer zum hörfunk
führt und die nummer eins ist die
nummer eins auch im tierreich der könig
der tiere
der löwe zwei bis vier männchen wesen
hier eine gemeinschaft gemeinsam macht
die jagd auf weibchen unter
unterstützen sich dabei gegenseitig
löwinnen klar zu machen
sie machen quasi das prinzip des ringens
zu ihrer bevorzugten methode ihre
gemeinschaft wird durch gemeinsamen sex
gesetzt das waren die top-10
homosexuellen tierarten wobei die
reihenfolge absolut willkürlich war
ehrlich gesagt und es gibt noch weitere
zahlreiche homosexuelle tierarten die
man auf führen könnte wenn ihr kein
weiteres und video mit spannenden
lustigen und skurrilen thema city
verpasste polstern durch wir ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit den top
sieben tieren auf drogen sehr lustig wie
die an drogen kommt interessiert um den
kauflächen dann geht es auch schon los
und ansonsten gesandt